or here's something important our friend
Heslin figura sat on last week's show
you have a crime bill right now that
Cory Booker's baking for people to get
on board when we talk about mass
incarceration going from 500,000 in 1980
to 2.2 million now there are American
citizens who are locked up right now but
yet our concern is on those who are
trying to break in America but it is
also important to point out that 97% of
people in jail did not put took a plea
deal because they did not have adequate
representation some of the 90s hundreds
of people were destroyed through Bill
Clinton's crime bill and nothing's being
told about that I say she's talking
about the first step bill a historic
reform of the criminal justice system
that President Trump and his team have
worked hard to negotiate here's the
president today I'm thrilled to announce
my support for this bipartisan bill that
will make our community safer and give
former inmates a second chance at life
after they have served their time so
important he's right and this is a major
populist issue just as much as
immigration or trade let's remember what
positive populism is all about
pro-worker pro-family pro community bill
clinton's 1994 crime bill ended up
incarcerated millions of working
Americans far too many of them African
Americans for far too long
hurting their ability to work and earn a
living contributing to family breakdown
and helping to tear apart the social
fabric in our communities turning that
around is a fantastic accomplishment and
leaders from all sides are on board
you've got Mike Lee this bill would deal
with that and would tell judges that
they've got discretion to actually be
judges and it will make life better for
millions of Americans who one way or
another are affected by our federal
criminal justice system you got Lindsey
Graham what we're talking about is
basically creating a new sentencing
system that will give african-american
male and Hispanic male detainees a
chance to get out of jail it's the most
important bipartisan piece of
legislation in the Congress today you've
got Democrats including dick Durbin and
Cory Booker you've even got banjo
of all people check out his praise for
president Trump on this one I'll give
him a salute and an applause we've got
to come together to help the people at
the bottom and if you can't put politics
aside to help people who are suffering
and struggling in prison when there's
this shot to do something on a
bipartisan basis then I think we've
taken politics too far you'd think with
all that support this bill would easily
pass Congress that's what the bill
sponsored Senate Judiciary Chairman
Chuck Grassley is hoping hears his tweet
deal make her a real Donald Trump can
get a big bipartisan deal done this year
on criminal justice reform plenty of
time to pass first step act in December
will GOP senators and leader McConnell
stand in president Trump's way of
achieving major bipartisan victory or
join in historic and popular reform and
there's the problem there's one hitch in
all this Mitch Mitch McConnell seems to
think his only job in life is confirming
judges of course that is vital but so is
president Trump's agenda and it would
help if the Republican Senate majority
that could actually help pass it instead
he's blocking it he won't bring the
first step bill for a vote because well
it's not exactly clear we don't have a
whole lot of time left but the first
step is to finalize what proponents are
actually for there's been a lot of
different versions floating around and
then we'll whip it see where the vote
count is another objector is outgoing
Tennessee senator bob Corker a lot of
people like me are still trying to
understand what it does he said there'd
only been a higher level discussion of
whether we should attempt to do it hmm a
higher level I think the explanation is
on a much lower level the one that
Washington usually operates on money
blocking this bill would leave more
people in jail now who would be most in
favor of that the prison industry of
course and guess who's received more
money from private prison companies than
any other member of the Senate that's
right good old bob Corker don't bother
wiping the mud off on your way out of
the swamps senator and Mitch McConnell's
opposition to this bill which has
mystified many people makes a little
more sense when you discover that he has
received wait for it over half a million
from private prison companies and their
financial interests over the years never
mind cocaine Mitch this is corrupt Mitch
put people first not donors do the right
thing pass this bill tell me what you
think at Steve Hilton X and at next Rev
FNC